[Music]  is that a new job doing hero work I  couldn't have done this if you hadn't  taken over so well Pixar's Incredibles 2  in theatres June 15  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  I thought we were gonna go heard your  mother trampolining  superheroes are illegally defines Who I  am  we're not saying you have what someone  on TV said I was approached by this  tycoon most to talk about hero stuff  help me bring supers back into the  sunlight  we need Elastigirl you're supposed to do  a dad they want us to do it I don't know  that way why would they change math over  Dusseldorf do those are dogs in I was so  happy to be closer I couldn't have done  this if you hadn't taken over so well  I've got to succeed so she can succeed  can she get it Bob is tricky but I can't  keep giving him cookies done properly  parenting is a heroic act done properly  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  you